the prince has planted a young oak tree
specially flown to canada
from windsor park for decades all around
the world
it's been part of the royal day job the
queen
planting more than 1500 trees during her
reign
so it couldn't feel more fitting that
we're all being asked
to plant a tree for her platinum jubilee
it left me much to do
in windsor in march the prince of wales
watched by his mother planted the first
as patron of the project whether you are
an individual hoping to plant a single
sapling in your garden
a school or community group planting a
tree
a council charity or business intending
to plant a whole avenue of trees
or a farmer looking to create new
hedgerows
everyone across the country can get
involved
one of the founding partners royal mail
have planted trees in
every nation to kick-start the project
but the rest of us are being asked to
wait until the next planting season
starting in october giving schools
villages businesses
and individuals the summer to plan the
woodland trust
giving away 3 million saplings to
support it
trees are incredibly important features
of many landscapes and
in this country we could do with a lot
more of them which is the whole point
of the queen's green canopy but on top
of expanding tree and woodland cover
across the country this is also a
celebration of ancient trees and ancient
woodlands
the queen's green canopy will dedicate a
network of
70 ancient woodlands across the united
kingdom
and identify 70 important ancient trees
to mark the jubilee but significantly
it's also
another way of the royal family again
championing
the climate change agenda we recognise
that
as a nation we have huge numbers of
challenges ahead of us in terms of the
climate crisis
and to be honest the best technology we
have for sucking carbon out of the air
is the tree
so if the 22 million people who have a
garden in their household we're just put
one tree in
and everyone else we're just to
encourage uh to find somewhere else in
the country put a tree in the ground
then we'll be in a far better place to
address that crisis as well
next year will be an unprecedented
national moment
celebrating her 70 years as queen a
milestone never achieved by
any other british monarch marked by a
project that doesn't just look back
but is hoped will leave a lasting
environmental impact
for our future rhiannon mills sky news